The Joe Rogan experience.
We're also,
there's a concern about those systems
being vulnerable to third party
attacks. Yeah. So hacking. Yeah, that's a,
that's a fascinating question.
I think there is a whole discipline
called adversarial machine learning in AI,
which basically any kind of system
you can think of how we can feed it.
Examples,
how we can add a little bit of noise
to the system to fool it completely.
So there's been demonstrations
on Alexa for example,
where you can take a,
you can take a,
you can feed noise into the system that's
imperceptible to us humans and make it
believe you said anything.
So fool the system into thinking,
ordering extra toilet paper. I
Dunno. Uh, in the same for cars,
you can feed noise into the cameras
to make us believe that there is,
or there isn't a pedestrian,
there is or there isn't lane markings.
So someone could do this in theory,
at least
in a, in theory that's the big
difference is in theory is doable.
You can do demonstrations in practices
actually really difficult to do in the
real world.
So in the lab you can do it,
you can construct a situation where a
pedestrian can wear certain types of
clothing or put up a certain kind of sign
where they disappear from the system.
I have to ask you this because
now I just remembered this.
You'd be the perfect
person to talk about this.
I'm not sure if you remember this case,
but there was a guy named
Michael Hastings, Michael
Hastings with a journalist.
And, uh, he was, I believe
in Iraq or Afghanistan.
He was somewhere overseas and he was
stuck there because of this volcano that
erupted and I believe Iceland.
And he was over there for the Rolling
Stone magazine, uh, and doing,
doing an article about a general,
well,
he stayed there for a long time because
they were stranded because of the
volcano and they got real
comfortable around him. And, uh,
he reported a lot of the stuff that they
said and did that maybe they thought
that he probably wouldn't
have reported on,
including them saying disparaging things
about President Obama at the time.
Anyway, comes back, the general
was forced to resign. Um,
he was a beloved general and,
uh,
Michael Hastings was in fearing for his
life because he thought that they were
going to come and get him because these
people were very, very angry at him.
He wound up driving his car into a tree
going like 120 miles an hour and the car
exploded and the engine went flying.
And people that were the
conspiracy theorists were
saying they believe that that
car had been rigged to work autonomously
or that someone for some third party
bad person decided to, or good
person, depending on your perspective,
decided to drive that guy's car into
a fucking tree at 120 miles an hour.
Do you think that that and is
2011,
Michael Hastings def 12,
maybe 2012 I think that sounds great.
Let's see what it says.
2013, 2013. June, 2013.
Do you think that in 2013
that would have been possible?
Okay.
It's entirely possible. No,
I just wanted to say that.
[inaudible] shout out to the
Joe Rogan sub reddit. Okay.
Uh,
check that one off the list.
Jamie. Pull that up, chat off. Um,
Aye.
Whether it's possible is
an interesting question,
whether it's likely is another question.
I,
I think it's very unlikely and the
other most important questions,
that's something we should worry at scale,
but our future is cars being used
to assassinate essentially people.
I'm Russian,
so I've,
I've heard of those things being
done by our friend Putin of it. Um,
I think,
I think it's very unlikely that this
kind of thing would happen at scale,
that people would use this.
I think there'll be more effective ways
to achieve this kind of end for sure.
And I,
I just think it's a very difficult
technical challenge that uh,
uh,
if hacking happens,
it would be at a different level
than hacking the AI systems.
It'll be just hacking software,
right?
And hacking software is the kind of the,
the kind of thing that can happen
with anything. An elevator saw,
elevate a software or, uh, any
kind of software that operates,
any aspect of our lives could be hacked.
And that same kind of way. Right. My,
my question though was in 2013,
was that technology available where
they could take over someone's car?
Do you know what car it was?
Mercedes, I think it was an s class,
C C C C class as is. Yes, yes,
yes. But I, I don't think, oh
boy, this is like a no, it's,
listen, this has been
widely speculated. I know,
I'm just asking you because
you're actually an expert. I mean,
it's very rare that you get an expert in
autonomous vehicles and you get to run
a conspiracy theory behind them to see
if they can just put a stamp on it being
possible or not. Let me just say
that Alex Jones is a fishing,
not allowed to say MIT scientists says
she's exactly what he's going to try to
do. Uh, no, I, um, first of all,
let me back off and say I
am not a security expert,
which is a very important difference.
That is important.
So then a autonomous vehicle,
I'd build a autonomous vehicle systems.
I don't know how to make
them extremely robust.
The security to hacking attacks, right.
And have a lot of really good friends,
which are some of the coolest people.
Uh,
I know who are basically hackers
converted to security experts.
I would say though, loosely speaking,
I think the technology was there yes.
For with physical access to the car
to be able to control it. But I don't,
I think it's extremely unlikely.
That's what happened.
I agree.
I see where you're coming from.
I'm not asking you whether or not
it's likely that it happened and I'm,
I'm sure you don't even
have much information on the
case cause I had to explain
it to you. Right. That's right.
I'm the guy also had, uh,
some serious amphetamines in the system.
Um, they compared it to crystal Meth,
but the reality is he was a
journalist and most journalists,
I don't want to say most all lot are
on Adderall and Adderall is essentially
amphetamines. I mean, that's
what it is. It's real. It's like,
it's like next door neighbors
to crystal meth really is. Um,
he is it,
well you said it's possible they could
actually get it to turn the wheel.
Yes. I have to look at the
exact system. Like I said,
drive by wire thing that I
mentioned. Some systems are not, uh,
it's not so easy to turn.
The wheel actually could
get them to just
accelerate out of control.
He's going like 120 something miles
now and just slammed into a tree
entirely possible. Ah, you
can't do it twice. The, um,
the systems back then though, we're
far more primitive. Correct? Yeah. Uh,
yeah, but it's, it's really, again,
the, the attack vectors here. The,
so the way you hack these systems,
I have more to do with the software Lola
of software that can be primitive than
the high level AI stuff.
Right.
But my issue with was there's no
cameras on the outside of the vehicle,
like there is on Tesla today, which has
autonomous driving as an option as a, so,
okay.
I see your point now.
So he wouldn't be hacking the system
that perceives the world and act in the
world.
It would literally be malfunction that
forces it to not be able to brake,
accelerate uncontrollably,
which is, uh, you know,
it's a more basic kind of attack and then
control then making the car steer auto
lane. Yes, yes. That's a different,
that's what people worry about with
autonomous vehicles. Once more and more,
you're talking about potentially 10,
20 million lines of source code.
So there's all this code and
so obviously becomes, uh,
amenable,
susceptible to bugs that can
be exploited to hack the code.
And so people are worried,
uh,
legitimately so that these
security attacks would, uh,
would lead to these kind of,
um,
well at the worst case assassinations,
but really sort of just basic, uh,
basic attacks, basic a hacking
attacks. And I think it's,
I think that's something that people in
the automotive industry and certainly
Tesla's really working hard on and making
sure that the ad that everything is
secure, there's going to be, of course
vulnerabilities always. But, uh,
I think they're really
serious about preventing them.
But in the demonstration space,
you'd be able to demonstrate
some interesting ways to
trick the system in terms
of computer vision.
This all boils down to that
these systems are actually,
that are ones that are camera based,
are not as robust as our human eyes
are to the world. So like I said,
if you add a little bit of noise,
you can convince it to see anything to
us humans that look like the same road,
like the same three pedestrians,
costumes,
trawler a little person
on the camera lens,
the little cameras, right. You could get
down there with a sharpie. That's, that's,
that's the one attack vector. That's a
as draw stuff. But you jokingly say that,
but that's I believe is possible. The Sun
plays tricks on Cadillac, Super Cruise,
next generation system.
We'll address camera problem.
Oh well as long as the next generation
addresses that you fucking assholes.
The Sun plays tricks on it.
So next gen system is something you're
going to have to bring that Cadillac into
the dealership and they're going to have
to update the software, update it yet.
Whereas Tessa would just handle
that shit over the area. Yeah,
I got an update the other day. I was
like, all right, all right. Question.
Same as, so that, that's an
exciting, powerful capability.
But then the Boeing, the
flip side is, you know, uh,
it can significantly change the
behavior of the system. And there,
there could be a glitch that could be
a glitch that could be a bug that the
Boeing one's terrifying, especially
with a lot of, I mean, that number,
whatever it is, it's like 300
combined, 300 plus people dead,
maybe even 400. I mean, it's,
I don't even know how to think.
Think about that number. Yeah.
All from a software glitch,
the guy who created it or the girl who
quoted it must feel fucking terrible.
Yeah. And you kind of, you, you walk, man.
It's, it's, uh,
it's a lot of burden and it's one of the
reasons it's one of the most exciting
things to work on actually,
is the code we write has the
capability to save human life.
But the terrifying thing is also has
the capability to take human life.
And that's a, that's a weird place
to be as an engineer or directly,
a little piece of code. You know, I'll
write thousands of them a day. You know,
basically notes you're taking
could eventually lead to a,
somebody dying
[inaudible].